tonight I spoke to Britain's former
defense secretary Liam Fox MP and asked
him what is the foreign policy priority
now for Western leaders in terms of
coming up with pressing policy which you
think is more important to deal with the
Ukraine situation or to deal with Isis
oh I think they're different i think
that Isis is a military imperative it's
a security question that needs to be
dealt with by military means I think the
Ukraine is more of a political problem
and probably can be de-escalated by
political or diplomatic means if if the
parties involved want to be let's start
with Isis do you understand why Britain
has not yet joined in the American
military attacks well it seems to be
that what the British government is
looking for is a wider coalition with
partners in the region as well as just
the united states clearly that's were to
send a signal that this is not simply a
Western intervention I think however if
you're looking from an Isis perspective
they will still see it as a Western
intervention irrespective of whether or
not there are other partners involved
and they've made very clear in their
hostage selection for example that they
don't differentiate between the United
States which has been launching bombing
raids on them and Britain which has been
dropping Syrian eight british hostage
who's been sort of lined up to be next
as it were do you think that could be
holding the Prime Minister's hand back a
bit no I don't think so I think David
Cameron has been particularly clear and
i have to say particularly brave about
the way that he's approached this issue
it's it's it's a heartbreaking decision
to have to make because we all
understand what families must be going
through and it's very lonely and
difficult decision for any leader to
have to make and I hugely respect the
way that he's been very clear and firm
about it because if we won this then it
simply makes it more likely that other
hostages will meet a similar fate as the
two Americans that we've seen so far is
there an obvious military strategy to
deal with Isis they seem to be very
fast-moving and to have made quick
territorial gains well there are the
ultimate aim of course has to be that
the ground forces of Iraq hand of the
cards will be able to deal with Isis but
for the moment
the ISIS forces are too strong they need
to be degraded their command and control
needs to be diminished and their lines
of communication need to be interrupted
that will require air power that they
simply don't seem to have and then
further down the line worthy to launch a
ground counter-offensive they would
require close air support and again they
wouldn't be able to provide that
themselves although it's possible that
other allies not Britain or the United
States Arab countries would be able to
do that do you think they are inclined
to do that I think that they might but I
think from our perspective we have to
recognize the huge threat that Isis
actually pose humanitarian threat in the
region destabilization of the wider
region and as a source of jihadists who
would they will export if they're given
the chance they are our enemy they have
to be defeated as far as Ukraine is
concerned you said you think that's more
of a political problem yet fighting is
going on why do you say that well I
think that the the root of the problem
is that the West has allowed Putin to
prod us without adequate responses from
the cyber attack on Estonia to the
invasion of George or the cutting off of
Ukraine's gas I think all these have
emboldened President Putin I think that
at heart they have a very different
world view they still believe that they
should have a sphere of influence and
all the old Soviet thought process that
says they should have a veto prospect on
the copies that were as a well so what
you know they used to occupy these
countries why not let our view is very
clear sovereign nations must be allowed
to exercise self determination that's
quite a big gap between our world view
and the Putin worldview and that really
does lie at the heart of his approach
but you Said's been prodding us do you
think he can be pushed back without a
much more serious conflict well I think
it's up to the west now and we have a
perfect opportunity at the NATO summit
in Wales to say we're not going to put
up with this we are going to reinforce
NATO we are going to make sure that it's
perfectly clear that article 5 that an
attack on one is an attack on all that
that is going to be fully respected and
I think we need to have a permanent
force in the Baltic States upgrade at
baltic air defenses upgrade our
relations and
preparations with Poland and to have
increased numbers of NATO exercise I
mean you mentioned Poland one of the
kind of public spokesman who tends to
back Putin Putin has and endorses but
they've talked on Russian television
about maybe new king Poland I mean
doesn't that really scare you well
there's a lot of very loose talk and
none of this of course helps to diminish
the tension but you do have President
Putin who has dramatically increased his
defense budget including on new nuclear
programs he doesn't maintain a first use
doctrine or on nuclear weapons and I
think that this is a this is telling us
increasingly about the salience of the
nuclear weapons issue finally you've
been writing about this today about NATO
members spending two percent of their
gdp on defense but truth is we're not
going to do that according to our own
redbook projections in this country we
know we really serious about defending
ourselves too well I think we should i
think that there's a great opportunity
for the prime minister to set at a
conservative position that says as the
economy grows we will continue to spend
two percent of our gdp on defense that
is what we're asking other NATO members
to do currently only four of us do that
you've got Poland coming up you've got
others coming up we should lead by
example and we should say Britain is
making very clear our commitment to our
collective security it's now up to
others to step up to the plate if we all
want the insurance policy we should all
be paying the premiums dr. Fox thank you